ea miklos gauche tony spécialiste de
l'afrique de l'est est chercheur à
l'iris l'institut des relations
internationales et stratégiques à
bonjour amis clos ce que je te dis merci
de répondre à nos questions en direct
sur arte france pourquoi les tensions
persistent entre civils et militaires
les militaires qui sont censés rendre le
pouvoir prochainement au printemps est
ce que vous pensez qu'ils tiendront
leurs promesses
écoutez c'est là la grande question qui
se pose bien sûr les 30 années au
pouvoir d'omar al-béchir et de son
régime ne vont pas disparaître et donc
pas desservis bien évidemment du jour au
lendemain
c'est un équilibre assez difficile qui a
eu lieu au soudan depuis l'établissement
du nouveau gouvernement
et cet été mais clip qui va continuer à
être très difficile
espérant jusqu'aux élections de fin 2022
équilibre difficile qui sans doute est
liée aussi bien à l'économique au
pouvoir qui que continue à avoir des
éléments de secte de défense dernier et
de l'apparat tus sécuritaire au sein de
gouvernements en souviens c'est le
triplement du prix du pain qui avait
déclenché la révolte en 2018 au soudan
cette année à l'inflation devrait
dépasser 140 % selon le fonds monétaire
international
elles encouragent l'instabilité
politique cette inflation est ce parce
qu'on doit s'attendre à de nouvelles
tensions à de nouveaux joueurs
écoutez en principe je ne vois pas
pourquoi ce serait pas le cas c'est à
dire la station connaît très très grave
et aussi la frustration de la population
vis-à-vis de la capacité du gouvernement
de se transformer vers des voies
démocratiques qui sans doute n'est pas
facile comme comme je les dis en ce qui
concerne l'économie
je pense que ce qui est vraiment
important c'est avec des gens la
décision de l'administration train
d'enlever le soudan de la liste des
états seront sûrs de l'héroïsme ça
devrait entraîner certains bénéfices
économiques par contre ceci ne va pas
être immédiat sarah prend du temps bien
sûr l'impact que pourrait avoir
des investissements potentiels étrangers
ne sera pas immédiat et aussi la levée
d'une partie de la date de ce soudain
dans le fmi et d'autres organismes
multilatéraux à partir de ce changement
de la politique des etats-unis aussi
n'aura pas un impact immédiat et aux
caraïbes pour aller plus loin sur ce
sujet quelles perspectives économiques
pour pour le soudan puisque vous venez
de dire le soudan peut commercer
désormais librement avec le reste du
monde puisque les états unis l'ont sorti
de la liste noire des pays qui
soutiennent le terrorisme
on rappelle quand même que khartoum a
accepté en contrepartie de normaliser
ses relations avec avec israël donc
quelles perspectives réellement
économique va écouter si bien dire ça va
pas être immédiat seul à prendre un
certain temps
la question est bien sûr est ce que le
gouvernement pourra tenir cette crise
économique
jusqu'à ce que éventuellement ses
bénéfices dans l'économie seront visible
pour la population ensuite bien sûr une
question de la politique c'est pas
simplement une question d'économie pure
et dure c'est aussi une question de
design de l'espoir que pour avoir la
population les rangs dans quelle mesure
à ce que le gouvernement pourra
transmettre un certain optimisme dans la
population à partir de ce changement
vous savez le soudan c'est un pays très
politique
le fait que où les gens sont très
politisés le fait qu' on a rallumé
scheer a pu rester au pouvoir 30 ans
c'est c'est une anomalie absolu dans
l'histoire du soudan
c'est le régime depuis l'indépendance
qui a duré le plus longtemps alors que
le second est un pays où l'activisme des
partis politiques surtout à khartoum a
toujours été très important donc dans ce
nouveau contexte il ya une
fonctionnalité sion assez marqué deux
des différents groupes qui aura fait
partie la révolution certains groupes
qui d'une manière active pouces pour une
politique beaucoup plus agressive des
civils au sein de gouvernements ou
mettre dix ans à fin au contrôle et au
pouvoir des militaires
et d'un autre côté dix ans les mobiles
et qui comprennent le mettre trop de
pression au premier ministre à bangkok
le entraîner un retour en arrière dans
quelle mesure un groupe où d'autres
restent autre question on sait que
depuis quelques semaines le soudan
accueille des dizaines de milliers de
réfugiés éthiopien le soudan est ce
qu'il prend un risque en ouvrant ses
frontières notamment de celui de se voir
entraîner dans un embrassement régionale
provoquée par la guerre civile en
ethiopie on le rappelle le récent
conflit entre les autorités éthiopiennes
et la région dissidente du tigre est
écouté oui déjà je dirais et
humanitaires le soudan était déjà en
grande mesure liée à la crise économique
de qui le traversent était déjà dans des
conditions humanitaires à c'est assez
grave
avec environ un tiers de la population
qui a besoin de l'aide humanitaire pour
vivre et donc ses sept arrivées de
déplacés
intégrer un dans le vent son territoire
pose encore plus de difficultés pour la
pour les organisations humanitaires à la
réponse humanitaire et des besoins plus
importants en termes d'aidé manie terre
en termes de conflits vous savez il ya
eu même des petits accrochages en
principe hier avant-hier au bord de la
frontière où entre l'armée éthiopienne
et l'armée et l'armée soudanaise est ce
que cela risque militaire je pense que
c'est relativement limité je pense que
le principal
le principal problème qui se pose est de
réponse humanitaire pour pour aussi bien
les des populations vulnérables au
soudan que pour les que pour les
réfugiés tigres merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions à huis clos ce que je
tenais je rappelle que vous êtes un
chercheur à l'iris et spécialiste donc
de l'afrique de l'est